I heard about this you could never
really go back and do another sitcom the
fear would be how could I ever top
Seinfeld it's guaranteed you can't top
it you can't even get close to it it's
iconic
great [__] it up certain guys it's
like it's funny right away you talk good
enough to think I did that so do you I
know that I got caught in a you know
what we call the perfect storm a good
one right me and Larry fit together
perfect how did you know to team up with
him in comedy certain guys it's like
it's funny right away you're talking all
of a sudden in two minutes you've hit
into something hilarious you guys start
to talk and you say hey we've got to
write a sitcom together I mean so many
things in the back of Howard Stern it's
so distracting dude it looks like
[__] Minority Report anyway the whole
gist here is
um he was offered a hundred and ten
million dollars to make another stadium
in Seinfeld and this is going viral
right now I knew that actually I mean
he's so rich I guess so it doesn't
matter
but also man
yeah you gotta do what you want to do I
I respect that [__] decide that you're
going to see who can go the longest
without masturbating that was Larry
David's idea NBC didn't say uh hey
you're mentioning masturbation you never
said the word
never never a while and I had the
impression you did so it worked it
worked and they there was not there was
one sponsor pulled out
one sponsor pulled out of the show that
was all I remember in terms of lotion
if any sort of blow back on that Kleenex
Warren Littlefield wrote that if you
would have given him another season in
of Seinfeld here we go he would have
paid you 110 million dollars for the
year
110 million dollars I could have got
more than that
oh dude
laid down the [__] Hammer right there
okay you could have gotten more than
that and you said no right is that the
ultimate in Integrity you were done
you know it wasn't Integrity why do they
sound so good and we don't sound that
good this [__] is all he wanted a door
to the wanted and he got the wanted it
and I'm over here and it's cracking and
[__] we gotta [__] level up this
audience he's a nice word and uh a a
flattering word I appreciate that but
to be honest you know uh which is what's
fun about coming on your show is if you
just really want to be honest right
because that's what you bring to the
show okay
um wow okay come on tween the people
that were making the show and the
audience okay
it was so white hot I I had to respect
that
and I could not go
to that point where it starts to
age and wither and it cannot be and it
doesn't take long for example you go see
a gradient at an hour and 10 minutes you
love the guys so now we're still long
it's like I agree I thought he was never
going to finish you walk out with a
whole different feeling it's a small
amount of too much
too much cake too much anything but I
agree and changes the whole feeling
about so we had this wonderful intense
love affair right the people are making
the show and the audience and I wanted
it to end
with a like a fireworks
not me dude
not me
bro if I get that [__] I'm riding it out
until the show [__] sucks so bad that
people are mad about it and somebody
stabs me
there's no [__] way
I'm doing another one I'm paying for the
for it at the end I'm doing well I'm I'm
not stopping I'm doing it I'm bringing
it to YouTube I'm gonna film it on my on
my iPhone just one shot [__] it
never was bad and also that last season
you lost said it was never bad could
have got more was never bad eh
you know unreal crazy
[Music]
you're crazy